Привет! С прошлого урока у вас уже есть бриф. Вы знаете, кто ваш пользователь, какие сценарии,
какие ограничения. Следующий вопрос: а что уже есть на рынке? Ваш будущий пользователь уже,
конечно, чем-то пользуется. Он привык к определенным паттернам и у него уже есть ожидания. Если вы не
знаете, как устроены продукты в вашей нише, вы проектируете вслепую. Можно скачать 10 приложений,
потыкать, поскриншотить, собрать Figma-доску. Обычно так и делаем, но полдня на нормальный обзор,
пожалуй, нужно. Мы сделаем это быстрее и двумя способами. Для ресёрча у нас есть два инструмента,
и каждый закрывает свою задачу. Это, наверное, даже не столько два инструмента, как два пути. Путь А — это
быстрый ресёрч внутри агента. Агент читает бриф, сам находит конкурентов, входит в интернет, собирает
фичи, цены, UX-паттерны. Результат сохраняет файл прямо в проекте. Весь контекст остается в одном месте,
этого достаточно для большинства задач. Но, конечно, качественные исследования дают больше
профита. Лучше изучить поглубже, тем более, если мы делаем это автоматически, почему бы этим не
воспользоваться? Тут у нас есть путь Б — это глубокий ресёрч через Gemini Deep Research. Это отдельный
инструмент от Google, заточенный именно под исследования. Если ты уже купил подписку на
найти Gravity, то у тебя доступ к этому инструменту есть полный. За один запрос этот
инструмент обходит десятки источников, перекрёстно проверяет данные, делает несколько итераций поиска,
и результат — это развернутый отчёт со ссылками. Это больше подходит для задач, где нужна глубина,
тренды рынка, статистика, анализ отзывов за длительный период, то есть как можно больше информации. Я уже
подготовил для вас директивы, поэтому нам не нужно самим придумывать ни как формировать
prompt, ни что спрашивают в Deep Research. Агент уже знает наш проект, он пересчитал бриф,
он видит контекст, попросим его, и он сгенерирует точный prompt для Deep Research с конкретными
вопросами, которые вытекают из вашего проекта, и которые закрыть самостоятельно пока не удалось.
Вы копируете prompt в Gemini, получаете отчёт, сохраняете в проект, и агент подхватывает результат
на следующем шаге. Итак, как я сказал ранее, для каждого пути я подготовил директиву,
готовый prompt, который вы кидаете агенту. Давайте посмотрим оба. Итак, первая директива - это
быстрый конкурентный research. Давай откроем его в превью, чтобы было удобнее смотреть. Задача - провести
конкурентный анализ на основе брифа проекта. Прочитай бриф, на основе описания продукта, аудитории,
ключевых фич, найди 5 основных конкурентов. Также по каждому конкуренту мы определяем основные
моменты, которые нужно изучить. Ключевые фичи, монетизация, UX, плюсы и минусы - это прям база-база. Если нужно что-то дополнительно, ты спокойно
это в MD файлике можешь дополнить. Формат результата - сохранить файл в competitive анализ MD, то есть в такой же MD файлик, который также можно будет тут открыть.
ниже описана структура файла, что должна быть таблица сравнения, краткий вывод по каждому конкуренту и общие выводы для нашего продукта. Где ниша, в чем может быть сильнее, какие паттерны
стоит перенять. Не просто сбор информации, а еще и его анализ и предложение каких-то решений. И теперь второй файлик - directive deep research prompt.
опять же эти файлы будут все у вас в материалах к уроку. Что у нас тут? Давай также через превью
посмотрим. Тут задача уже сгенерировать
детальный промпт для Gmini Deep Research на основе того, что есть в брифе и опять же некоторые структуры. В общем здесь описано, что мы должны привязываться конкретно
к нашим задачам, к нашей структуре, к нашему брифу и не дублировать то, что мы сделали на шаге с поверхностным исследованием. Здесь также указано, что есть competitive
анализ МД, то есть есть результаты первого исследования, то он их использует. Если нет, то ну просто формирует промпт с нуля. Давай я выберу
первый МД файл, первую директиву и просто ее перетяну сюда, закину ему даже без объяснения, что нужно сделать. Мы уже в этом чатике, где мы прошли бриф, он
полностью знаком со всем контекстом, поэтому можно сразу закидывать и я думаю он подхватит. Да, он говорит о том, что запустил конкурентный
ресерч по брифу, будет исследовать 5 конкурентов параллельно. Нашел ключевых конкурентов TimeWeb, Selectel, DigitalOcean.
Итак, он прошел весь флоу и собрал нам конкурентный анализ. Какой-то более простой. Можем также через превью
посмотреть, чтобы у нас таблицы нормально отражались. Все, у нас есть сравнительная таблица по тем
возможностям, которые предоставляют разные конкуренты. Выбрал там главных конкурентов, цены, тестовые периоды. В общем вся информация,
самое важное по итогам нашего брифа. Как видите, здесь достаточно много пунктов. Краткие выводы и общие
выводы для нашего продукта, что важнее всего подметить у каждого. Уже очень неплохо, но мы можем пойти
дальше. Берем нашу вторую директиву, также его в окно чата перетаскиваем и закидываем. Я тут пытался
выяснить, почему он сказал, что у него нет доступа в интернет, но он на самом деле просто галлюцинировал.
Итак, он создал новый файлик Deep Research Prompt. Сделал это опять же за несколько секунд. Выделил основные
проблемы, которые нужно изучить глубже. Мы просто заходим сюда, нажимаем Ctrl+A,
выбираем отсюда весь текст и переходим в Gemini. Так, давай сделаю fullscreen. Теперь сюда, как ни странно,
мы просто закидываем весь наш промпт и здесь в Tools выбираем Deep Research. Можно выбрать модель покруче,
я не буду просто, чтобы сэкономить время. Отправляю ему наш промпт. Итак, он здесь разметил план исследований на
эту тему, выделил основные тейки, последняя возможность убедиться, что он все правильно понял и после чего
можно начать исследование. Если нет, то план можно избирать. Итак, он провел исследование. Исследование,
как мы видим, достаточно большое. Тут и динамика российского облачного рынка, объем рынка, процентный
рост, рост в процентах, профиль криптоаудитории и так далее. То есть, ну я там на этапе брифования выбирал, что у нас
через крипту будет оплачиваться, просто рандомно тыкал, чтобы поинтереснее были результаты. И тут он именно в
контексте использования крипты и вот этих облачных серверов провел исследование аудитории, посчитал даже
экономику, сколько будет нам стоить в среднем отвечать на какие-то вопросы биллинга и так далее. То есть, ну,
исследование очень большое. Подробно мы не будем читать, он здесь собрал еще все источники, все
ссылки, с которыми можно более подробно будет в этом контексте ознакомиться. Собрал рекомендации,
в общем, огромное исследование сделал, чего теперь с ним нам делать. Мы можем, во-первых,
копировать, копировать это все как текст и вставлять обратно в нашей среде, но нейросеть все поймет в
таком случае, но нам будет неудобно с этим работать. Либо экспортировать в доке, вот наш документ
загружается и здесь экспортировать как md файл download markdown. Но у меня почему-то не срабатывает
сейчас, возможно, эта проблема как-то будет решена, мы можем пойти по другому пути. Экспортировать это как
docx. Это получается всегда. И перейти по ссылке, которая будет под уроком. Здесь можно конвертировать
этот docx в нормальный md-формат, который будет удобно смотреть в среде. Конвертируем в markdown. И полученный
результат мы можем закинуть в свою среду. Здесь же как-нибудь переименовать его,
rename, например, deep search results. Все. Получили всю нашу информацию. Теперь можем его также в качестве превью открыть,
увидеть, что тут у нас все таблички работают, все то же самое по сути. И в дальнейшем уже переиспользовать
именно эти исследования для дальнейшей разработки нашего продукта. Итак, еще раз, что мы сделали?
Сначала скормили для первичного ресерча наш бриф исходный, получили какое-то там небольшое исследование,
сделанное именно агентом. Если агент 5-10 источников проверит, то deep research порядка 50. Соответственно,
там намного глубже будут исследовать. Поэтому, если это необходимо, мы запускаем следующую директиву,
которая для deep research у нас формирует prompt. В этом prompt учитывается сразу и результаты брифа и
результаты первоповерхностного исследования. На выходе мы получаем prompt для deep research,
идем в Gemini, закидываем его и получаем уже полноценное исследование. Это исследование мы
конвертируем в MD-формат и возвращаем в нашу среду, благодаря чему можем продолжать работать в ней же,
сохраняя весь контекст с небольшим совсем отклонением от работы внутри агентов. Итак,
домашнее задание. Берете тот продукт, который выбрали на прошлом уроке и проводите оба
research. Сначала быстрый через агента и затем глубокий через deep research. По сути делайте
все то же самое, что я сделал в этом уроке. Директивы будут в материалах к уроку. Когда будет
готово, можете сравнить, что дал deep research такого, чего не было в быстром research. Появились ли
дополнительные инсайты, может быть что-то удивило, формат сдачи будет такой. Скрины готовых
результатов обоих research и ваши выводы, что новое узнали и что пригодится дальше именно в рамках
этого проекта. В следующем уроке мы возьмем эти файлы и оформим из них полноценный конкурентный
анализ со свод, таблицей фич и UX паттернами. Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания. До встречи в следующем уроке.